[music]
>> If a Japanese
like mashallah our brother here who
knows Japanese
and if I employ him in Bombay
I may benefit but I'm decreasing the
spread because he's a Japanese.
He knows Japanese very few people know
Japanese and who can be a good guy. So
if I train a Japanese in doing Dawah
and keep him in Bombay point number one,
a foreigner can't do missionary activity
in India.
Can't give public lectures.
But we asked only to check.
What is his passion? Is he willing to
sacrifice or not? A person coming from
UK wanting to work in Bombay ah passion
is good. Just to check.
Would you like we didn't say yes we'll
employ you.
Yes, there were
one or two participants like brother
mashallah Shafiq
who will be beneficial to us because we
have launched a channel in Mandarin.
So we want a person knowing English and
Mandarin.
We have a few Chinese mashallah there
with us. Pure Chinese but they know
Arabic and Chinese not English and
Mandarin. So there are a couple of
foreigners who would be staying
inshallah and working with us but that
will benefit them because what work he
can do in Bombay can't do anywhere else
in the world.
He being able to reach
millions of people through Peace TV he
cannot do that in Malaysia.
But I don't have a Japanese channel so
if I ask him to stay here
he would be a better impact
for the Islamic world in Japan than
here.
So as the policy we had two different
rules for them then I told brother Kalim
that okay fine if they're hardly two
Indians who have
come into the list by default. Let's ask
the other Indians
that will you work here?
So 80% agreed yes. So from that lot we
had a second category
that fine you will be observing the
Dawah training program on a screen in a
side room.
Yet you will benefit more than 75% how?
Your homework would be taken by another
instructor no problem. You will not be
able to ask me questions on the spot.
But maybe thrice
in 33 days I would give them a couple of
hours two hours or three hours. You jot
down the questions I will answer once in
10 days maybe.
Under the condition
that you agree to work your full time.
That was a condition.
For attending the Dawah training program
it was a question and there were some
people who also said we will not work
here but we selected them.
In the international training program.
In the next room it was only
that fine you did not qualify for the
main round. Now there's a second or that
is costing me money which is not
benefiting the ummah.
Why? Because that's not going on
satellite.
Your mic cost per person is very
expensive. There also there's a cost
involved.
It's in lakhs of rupees. Lakhs of rupees
means thousands of dollars.
Several thousand dollars there. Here?
It's in big amount.
So there we had mentioned in the form
very clearly
that simple and basic accommodation will
be given.
If anyone wants
something better
he'll have to pay for it.
So that we are clear now.
We are clear.
Simple and basic now simple and basic
what is for you
may differ for me.
What is for you may differ for me it is
subjective I know that.
Now for the foreigners what
accommodation we gave we think it is
basic and simple.
They may think it is good they may think
it is low it is up to them.
I may have to take a survey maybe.
What we felt basic and simple for an
Indian irrespective whether he's coming
from China or whether he's coming from
he's an Indian.
The policies were different. He did not
qualify for the main round.
So we had another accommodation which
was in the apartments.
Which is basic and simple which is
when I travel the world
I stayed in accommodation worse than
that.
Dr. Zakir Naik.
When I went to UK they kept me in a room
which was little bigger than the bed I
slept on.
Allah has given me so much money that
mashallah I can stay in five star hotel
anywhere in the world. Alhamdulillah.
Allah has given that to me.
We didn't object. We said alhamdulillah
they gave me a chance to do Dawah no
problem.
I paid for my ticket.
Not to learn. They call me I pay my
ticket. They charge for my entry. They
make money.
I pay for my ticket.
And I have a habit when I prepare I walk
in the room.
Imagine 6 ft by about 5 ft room.
I'm talking about the old days in the
early 2000s.
We didn't object.
Surely the accommodation we gave here is
multiple than better than the
accommodation when I traveled.
Alhamdulillah. Now the situation is
different. Alhamdulillah.
We want to test not that we can't
afford. Whenever we call English speaker
for Peace TV all of them we don't give
five star we give five star deluxe.
It's not required.
We want to tell the guy okay fine we
give you the best treatment.
When our budget of this Dawah training
program is so big we can keep all of you
in the five star deluxe. We don't want
to spoil you. We don't want to degrade
your niyah.
If you want to stay in a five star for
Dawah training
why to waste the ummah's money?
Alhamdulillah we can afford to keep all
of you in five star deluxe. That is the
capacity of organization.
One participant who I mentioned earlier
in the session I don't take his name. He
had said that please give me I don't
mind coming if there's no suite I sit in
the side room. I'll pay for my
accommodation etc. And when he came here
he said the accommodation is not up to
standard. So I said fine.
You are willing to pay
you can pay.
I told brother Kalim that if he wants
accommodation better than what we have
given
he'll have to pay minimum 3,000 rupees a
day.
But Kalim was afraid he said 2,000 a
He said I'll go back.
That means he can't pay 2,000 a day for
this training.
And he's a guy.
He's a guy giving lectures.
I said alhamdulillah.
We saved the money of the ummah.
For that.
And he's earning good money. He said I
earn a lot of money I can pay for my
accommodation.
So one thing is speaking one thing is
you know
most of the foreigners that have come
if I tell them to pay they will pay.
I know we don't require alhamdulillah.
Because we can judge the enthusiasm of
each one.
We don't want to spoil.
If a person comes here because we are
giving good accommodation how will we
die?
But we don't want to trouble him too
much. Therefore we said the basic for
the foreigners would be Balwas Hotel.
Four star hotel.
We can afford the most expensive hotels
here. Alhamdulillah Allah has blessed
us.
People come and say that if they want to
learn in my school we would not mind
going in a hut and learning.
Suppose tomorrow you come to know the
place is unclean. What do you think you
won't do the Dawah training program?
Hypothetically if I have to study under
Deedat I would live in a hut on the
streets also.
Even if I have to pay a million dollar
and I can afford it I will pay.
Because that money cannot buy that
training.
Those who value
they know. Those who don't value
and neither do we want to be
extravagant.
A person come there the speaker is on a
different level.
You are coming as students to learn yet
we don't want you to be
something substandard.
If a person who thinks living in
apartment where we kept most of our
staff are staying there
that is fine and if he thinks that it is
not up to the standard and he wants to
go I said no even he wants to do I will
not allow. I want to search somewhere
where I can get. I said even if he gets
the place he cannot continue.
He cannot start but alhamdulillah he
himself ran away.
So Allah subhana wa ta'ala helps us many
a time
to find out
what is the real test.
Inshallah we have to end the session
within the next few minutes because it's
time for Maghrib salah. I'll just rush
through.
Point number five, need help to identify
the qualities of Dawah in me as Dr.
Zakir, Yusuf Estes, Hamza Yusuf, Nouman
Ali Khan are very different in their
ways but very effective and I might be
more suitable towards one style and not
all.
Hence helping me to nourish the best of
my qualities to give Dawah in the way of
Allah effectively.
Being just effective is not important.
Being effective on lines of Quran and
Sunnah is more important.
There are mashallah guys who are
effective but they're far away from
Quran and Sunnah.
So if you want to be an effective guy
away from Quran and Sunnah
that's the reason always before
selecting do your homework.
If you are going to spend here 45 days
with me and if you have not done
homework on me you are a big fool.
I'm not telling you I'm just telling in
general.
You have to do your homework.
There are many people who are effective
but
when you say Zakir says become an
effective guy it's understood on the
lines of Quran and Sunnah.
Why? Because I've seen his speech always
Quran and Sunnah.
There may be other guys who may have
programs but their effectiveness is not
on line of Quran and Sunnah.
Correct?
So being effective on the lines of Quran
and Sunnah is the most important other
than only be effective.
Point number six, I would like to know a
clear long-term and short-term career
plan with IRF as I would be joining as
employee from day one and what are the
company's
expectation towards us so that I can
plan for the best in this career and
gain blessing of Allah Subhana Wa
Ta'ala. One thing is that that if you
work in IRF,
one of the major benefits is the chances
of you getting benefit in the Haram.
One point.
Others all
negligible. Last point, inshallah, free
access to the library as I would like to
spend my time reading from Islamic books
from your library. To have free access
today, you don't have to travel.
Everything is there on the net.
This is the age of science and
technology. You don't have to join an
organization to have access to the
books.
The books are available on the net, most
of it, alhamdulillah.
We are running short of time and we have
to break for the salah. The last
expectation
we'll just finish fast. That's Safarik
Naik. Eight expectations. Number one,
knowing that many people will inshallah
benefit as it is aired on Peace TV and
also the participants can later have
such courses in the countries.
Inshallah. Number two, achieving a
holistic approach of Dawah to
non-Muslims as Dawah is compulsory on
every Muslim, so fulfilling obligation.
Inshallah. Point number three, making
the appropriate use of Quran and Hadith,
reason, logic and science for promoting
the message of Islam in the best and
most effective manner to gain solely the
pleasure of Allah Subhana Wa Ta'ala.
Now, here's the expectation. The only
expectation amongst all
the students is making the appropriate
use of Quran and Hadith, reason, logic
and science for promoting the message of
Islam is the best and the most effective
manner
to gain solely the pleasure. Most of you
said effective Dawah, but Farik says no.
Using knowledge of Quran and Sunnah,
reason, logic, science, promoting and
then becoming effective, which was
covered in the last point.
His is the biggest, longest expectation.
Number four, learning the art of Dawah
in terms of public speaking, one-to-one
and other ways of Dawah through media,
newspapers and magazines as media is the
most important tool of Dawah, inshallah.
Point number five, learn various aspects
of Islam beyond Dawah like leading a
religious life by involving oneself in
Islamic activities. The best way to
involve oneself in Islamic activities,
inshallah. Point number six, how to run
and operate a Dawah organization in
terms of effectiveness of the
organization and Islamic activities
including Dawah. Also knowing the
administrative and technical aspects
related to the organization. Point
number seven, the effective use of the
available sources in the most cheap and
impressive manner to convey the message
of Islam, example, Peace TV. The budget
of per person watching is very cheap.
Inshallah, we'll discuss this on the
seventh day when we have Dawah through
satellite.
And the last, he has given eight
expectations. We asked for seven, he
gave it. The techniques of debate
because in a debate it is not the one
with more knowledge who wins, but rather
the one who has the skills and
techniques of debating.
Inshallah, may Allah Subhana Wa Ta'ala
make it possible for you to achieve all
these eight expectations I mentioned.
And we break for Maghrib salah, we are
late. Please offer your salah fast.
And inshallah, we'll meet tomorrow.
Inshallah, be at 7:25 sharp so that we
can start the session 8:00 tomorrow
morning sharp on the second day, that is
dealing, inshallah, with the
introduction to Dawah. Wa akhiru dawana
alhamdulillah rabbil alamin.
>> [music]
[music]